stage 1 tanks pressing for flight C - 15
seconds six five four nine three eight
two seven zero so Rhys got a new era of
American space flight they fought the
Bolton emotions of a new generation
continuing the dream 20 seconds into
flight stage one propulsion is nominal
b-boss 30 seconds into this historic
mission flying crew aboard riggan and
Falcon - look at him go
Falcon pyrometry nominal
and 1d throttle down we're throttling
down to get ready for the period of
maximum dynamic pressure we're in the
throttle bucket
reports say all systems are go
[Music]
vehicle is supersonic
we've exceeded Mach 1 on the Falcon 9
and one do you throttle up
we're throttling back up the full powers
we're through let's go
copy one Bravo
[Music]
and we heard that one Bravo call-out
that's just the second abort zone that
they're in they will continue to be on
this until the first age has done its
job and they switch over to the second
at this point five and duck pulling
about 2.3 G's 2.3 times the Earth's
gravity already 1300 1500 miles per hour
we've heard to call out for EM back
engine chill that's getting the impact
engine ready to light that'll come in
about to 44 into flight right now
everything continuing to look good next
major event coming up is going to be the
triple we'll have main engine cutoff of
the nine first stage engines stage
separation and an ignition of the second
stage engine to continue to carry
astronauts into orbit
coming up in about 20 seconds and 1d
throttle down we heard we're throttling
down the merlin engines on the first
stage
and we have Miko because Falcons stage
separation confirmed
and recognition all right we have stage
separation confirm the first stage
beginning its flight back the second
stage being powered by that single
merlin 1d vacuum engine has ignited and
is that Bob and Doug into orbit so
they're gonna continue under the power
of this second stage new propulsion is
nominal which will cut off at Seco or
second engine cut off at about 8 minutes
and 44 seconds into today's flight so a
little over 5 minutes to go still on
this second stage you're hear the call
out to alpha so they're now in the
longest abort zone that carries them all
the way from about North Carolina up the
eastern seaboard almost to Canada things
looking good though getting good
call-outs nominal for propulsion on that
second stage 5 no continuing to make
their way into orbit
dragon SpaceX nominal trajectory so the
SpaceX Falcon 9 rocket lifting off there
from Kennedy Space Center in Florida
launching NASA astronauts Doug Hurley
and Bob Behnken onto their 19 hour
journey to the International Space
Station the first spaceflight for NASA
astronauts from US soil in nine years